Let's pray together over day 38, Holiness in the
Emotions.
Father, thank you for the assurance that
your Holy Spirit calls us to a holiness that is
complete, not just in our spirit or in our will,
not just in our body, not just in our mind,
but that your holiness has called to us to go all the
way down to the core of our being, to where we really
live.
And we thank you for the opportunity to be holy in our emotions.
Lord, I would pray that you would help us today, that as we
give to you our emotions, as we place them before you in full
surrender,
that you would take those emotions and that you would revamp them.
Would you use, Lord, the gift of imagination,
and instead of letting it lead us toward corruption and
lust and fear and anxiety, instead, Lord,
I pray that you would help us to be able to create joy
in you, create joy in who you are and in the glory of your
character.
Lord, I pray that you would give us the grace to cherish
you and to rejoice in you and to see you in
all the beauty of your character, all the glories of
your attributes. Lord, you are all of the
things that we need. You are the water of life.
You are the bread. You are the treasure in the field.
You are the pearl of great price. You are the strong tower.
You are the wind that blows through our lives and gives us the
freshness. You are our Lord of Hosts, the Lord of angel
armies. You are all of these things, and we pray for the grace
to feel as though it were true, to see it with
clarity in our emotions, in our
imaginations, so that what we know to be true in our
minds would soak down and touch our emotions.
We pray, O Lord, that you'd let yourself be very real to us today, not
just in our hearts or not just in our minds, but in our emotions as
well. In Jesus' name.
Let's continue praying together as we seek the Lord for holiness in our
emotions.